[Música]
gracias al Triunfo de la senadora
Catherine Cortés en el estado de Nevada
los demócratas mantienen el control del
senado en Estados Unidos ahora el foco
está en el estado de Georgia que
realizará una segunda vuelta el 6 de
diciembre
en Perú restan algunos requisitos
legales para que pase a votación ante el
pleno del Congreso el proceso con el que
buscan inhabilitar por cinco años al
presidente Pedro castillo y también
acusarlo de traición a la patria
ampliamos la información desde Lima
y en Bolivia el presidente Luis Arce
anunció que mantiene el censo
poblacional la oposición en Santa Cruz
ha solicitado al gobierno central que
realiza el censo en 2023 para que de
esta manera reciban más recursos y
puedan ampliar su base de Diputados
Hola Bienvenidos a esta informativo de
France 24 en el que hacemos foco en los
principales temas los más destacados del
continente americano vamos a comenzar en
Estados Unidos en donde los demócratas
retuvieron el control del senado después
de una victoria clave en el estado de
Nevada por parte de la senadora
demócrata Katherine Cortés veamos a esta
hora entonces cómo queda configurada la
cámara en este momento en el senado los
demócratas entonces obtienen 50 escaños
a los que se suma un escaño más de
desempate que podría llegar por parte de
la vicepresidenta kamala Harris lo que
les daría la mayoría para retener el
control de la cámara alta ahora la
atención está concentrada en el estado
de Georgia en donde los demócratas
también van a defender un escaño
adicional que será disputado en una
segunda vuelta que está prevista para el
6 de diciembre
y a su turno el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden dijo mostrarse
complacido por el resultado obtenido
Asimismo a través de una publicación en
la red social Twitter el senador
demócratas chuck's líder de la mayoría
en el senado de Estados Unidos se
refirió al hecho de que su partido
mantenga el control de la cámara alta
los demócratas volverán a tener mayoría
en el senado esta elección es una
victoria y una reivindicación para los
demócratas nuestra agenda y nuestros
logros para Estados Unidos y el pueblo
estadounidense vamos a Perú en donde hay
reacciones tras la aprobación de un
informe que solicita que el presidente
Pedro Castillo sea inhabilitado por
cinco años y se le acuse también por el
delito de traición a la patria dicho
proceso deberá cumplir otros requisitos
legales antes de su eventual votación en
el congreso peruano desde la Ciudad de
Lima Francisco Zacarías nos da más
detalles
el presidente Pedro Castillo ha sido
citado por el congreso de Perú el
miércoles 16 de noviembre a una sesión
de la comisión permanente del parlamento
para el debate y votación de la denuncia
constitucional por traición a la patria
en su contra que fue aprobada por la
subcomisión de acusaciones
constitucionales el mandatario tendrá
una hora para ejercer su defensa si es
que la comisión permanente aprueba la
denuncia se convocará al pleno del
congreso para una sesión de debate y
votación donde se requieren 66 votos
para inhabilitar a Pedro Castillo Al
respecto del mandatario ha dicho que han
inventado denuncias y carpetas
constitucionales en su contra pero nunca
tendrán la razón por su parte la defensa
del gobernante rechaza el proceso porque
afirma que el congreso peruano no puede
aplicar el delito de traición a la
patria cuando no existe una sentencia de
por medio contra Pedro Castillo mientras
que diversos juristas sostienen que la
denuncia no tiene sustento legal porque
jamás entregó territorio peruano a
Bolivia y la denuncia puede jugar a
favor el presidente Castillo para
mostrar a la misión de la oea de que
existe la convicción de la oposición
para sacarlo del Poder De cualquier
forma los incondicionales de Pedro
Castillo confían en que una acción de
Amparo del mandatario contra el congreso
que fue admitido a trámite Por una corte
pueda frenar la denuncia por traición a
la patria y una eventual tercera moción
de vacancia presidencial en Bolivia el
presidente Luis Arce anunció que
mantendrá la fecha para realizar el
censo de población en el 2024 de esta
forma se mantiene el registro actual de
Cara a las elecciones del 2025 la
oposición y diferentes sectores
políticos de la ciudad de Santa Cruz de
la Sierra han solicitado al gobierno
central que realice el censo en el año
2023 para una necesaria actualización lo
que le permitiría también a este
departamento homónimo recibir más
recursos estatales y ampliar su base de
diputados
la tensión se mantiene en las calles de
Santa Cruz mientras el gobierno
boliviano no da su brazo a torcer y
mantiene el censo poblacional y de
vivienda para el 23 de marzo de 2024 el
presidente Luis Arce hizo un llamado a
la calma las bolivianas y bolivianos
queremos vivir en paz somos de la
cultura del diálogo y de la paz y por
eso llamamos a pacificar entre todas y
todos
el viernes se cumplían tres semanas de
protestas es el plazo que dio la
oposición de Santa Cruz para convocar el
censo poblacional en 2023 Durante este
tiempo ha habido cuatro muertos y más de
100 heridos se acaben los resguardo a
los masistas se acaben la violencia a
nuestra gente
[Aplausos]
y que estén con el pueblo que es lo que
Todos queremos el último censo se
realizó en 2012 el gobierno de Luis
arcelo retrasó de 2023 a 2024 alegando
el parón de la pandemia además de
bastión opositor Santa Cruz es la
segunda ciudad del país y el principal
centro económico es la mayor receptora
de migración interna por lo que el
aumento de población le otorgaría más
recursos de hacerse el censo en 2023 la
región tendría tres diputados más en la
asamblea para las elecciones de 2025 Sin
embargo esta protesta se limita a Santa
Cruz y no tiene apoyo en el resto del
país tampoco es un apoyo masivo de forma
interna Ya que el movimiento al
socialismo es el segundo partido más
apoyado en la región
no nos dejan circular no nos dejan pagar
no deja de hacer nada Santa Cruz fue
también en 2019 el lugar desde donde se
ideó el derrocamiento del gobierno de
Evo Morales
y seguimos en Bolivia la hoja de coca es
un símbolo ancestral y es consumido
habitualmente en las zonas Rurales de
ese país pero gracias a las migraciones
internas ahora es muy común ver en las
grandes ciudades bolivianas a personas
de las clases altas más cando coca su
consumo se ha vuelto muy popular lo que
ha llevado a un impulso de su producción
en las zonas Rurales de Bolivia más
carcoca es parte de la vida misma y esto
se está extendiendo cada vez más a las
ciudades que con esta apropiación
también acaban con el estigma
beneficiándose de las propiedades de la
planta ancestral hoy en día lo consumen
todo de
doctores policías es como energizante
natural alivia mucho el estrés y se
quita te quita mucho
el cansancio este Boom tiene especial
peso en Santa Cruz la segunda ciudad de
Bolivia es el principal centro económico
y de recepción de migrantes los locales
al ver los efectos que tiene la coca en
los indígenas se han acercado a su
consumo y cada vez hay más iniciativas
desde saborizantes como la maracuyá
sofisticados brebajes y llega hasta las
exclusivas fiestas de la ciudad hay
mucho mucha gente
hay una gente que en camba tradicional
así está el su popularidad que ha
llegado a las esferas de la fama como
Daniel Novoa conocido como boloman con
más de 200.000 seguidores en tiktok con
vídeos humorísticos sobre la coca en la
mayoría quizás todo no son menos de los
que no estoy volando el mercado de la
coca solo puede crecer en Bolivia la
hoja ancestral está clasificada como
substancia controlada por las Naciones
Unidas sin embargo Bolivia pudo crear
una excepción por la importancia de la
coca en el país y Brasil registró el
pasado mes de octubre una de las mayores
cifras de deforestación estos datos
coinciden con la visita del presidente
electo Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva a
Egipto para asistir a la Cumbre con 27
en donde ha captado la atención debido a
su interés por el tema medioambiental
la deforestación de la selva amazónica
de Brasil no se detiene a pesar de las
alarmas que ha generado nacional e
internacionalmente esta va en aumento
este octubre el país registro 904
kilómetros cuadrados de área talada unas
120.000 canchas de fútbol y un aumento
del 3% con respecto al mismo mes en 2021
según el Instituto Nacional de
investigaciones espaciales además el
país rompió otro preocupante récord la
deforestación acumulada entre el primero
de enero y el 31 de octubre de este año
fue de 9.494 kilómetros cuadrados la
mayor área desde que comenzaron las
mediciones en 2015
ante dicho panorama la ong fondo mundial
para la naturaleza en Brasil señaló que
las cifras podrían empeorar asegurando
que luego de las elecciones del país el
mes pasado los incendios forestales se
desataron de forma descontrolada
bolsonaro está a punto de irse y hay un
sentimiento entre los que se lucran con
la ilegalidad de que se está cerrando la
ventana de oportunidad el nuevo gobierno
tendrá mucho trabajo por hacer para que
el país vuelva a la normalidad para
acabar con esta percepción de que la
amazonía es una tierra sin ley
la amazonía es uno de los principales
puntos en la agenda Ambiental de la
izquierdista Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
el presidente electo ha asegurado en
múltiples ocasiones que revertirá las
estadísticas que deja su antecesor
respetaremos nuestra amazonía nuestra
selva
no habrá más minería ilegal en este país
no habrá más deforestación ilegal en
este país
durante el mandato de bolsonaro la
deforestación anual promedio en la
amazonía brasileña aumentó 75% Comparado
con la década anterior esto en las
noticias siga con nosotros
[Música]